oh um I was with my ex girlfriend for
like four and a half years after she
kept what I was like a period of just at
[ __ ] my dad dies ten days later my
grandma dies two months later my
ex-girlfriend cussed me out of her life
totally understandable from the person I
used to be but um I went through this
big single phase and III didn't go to
college and I didn't like date anyone
from as I start dating her before I was
18 up until I was like 22 23 and I
didn't know how to be single at all or
had a talk now it's like heroes like
how'd you get all these girls on the
channel I'm like dude I know how to be
friends owned like nobody's business so
I know how to make friends with girls
easily but I've never been that good at
like actually getting a girl interested
in me anyway so I went through this
single face and then I was going through
experimental phases and I turned to the
one thing I thought would work
craigslist org so they have the casual
encounters section right and so I did
some experimentation stuff with dudes
actually and I realized wasn't for me
wasn't for any where it come from yeah
it's the outlet now all the god yeah
yeah there's a drama to the comedy kids
so were you via who the man why she I
didn't have sex with these guys that's
okay they were some of them are really
interesting because they're like I'm not
gay I just want to suck a dick and I was
like okay so I didn't I never sucked a
dick I just I could never I can one time
someone offered and I was like nah I
don't something about of dick being in
my mouth just not cool so I was like you
were the at least you were the picture
pretty much yeah that's it yeah and then
one day I get hit
there's this um it's actually this it's
this black girl and I was like I've
never been with a black girl sweet huh
and I'm like finally a girl hits me up
right so I go over to her place it's
it's kind of like darkling and there's
only candles and then she tells me um I
want to massage you I want to lick you
from head to toe right and she literally
does that like everywhere everywhere
Tyra good so um yeah especially so then
Nick see no um there's a condom on me
and then she sits on me and so I'm in
her and then I realized wait a minute my
dicks in her ass then I reached down
totally out of Venus get the weight of
it no no no no no that's a job Dori
that's a true showering I hear these
stories all the time on life Jerry
Springer or Jenny Jones or something and
there will be guys there will meet these
women they would have sex with and not
know but they put a neck and you got no
you gotta tell cause she sat on me with
a skirt on and I couldn't see it was
until I reached down and was like oh
this is one of those situations about
something did you feel something like
only I reached my hands down and then I
was like that's a penis so Oh what what
did I do umm I I couldn't continue okay
oh wait oh there's more of the story I
couldn't I couldn't continue as out and
I was honest with this her that you know
like there's all these like people are
like you should refer to that person as
a her or a he like I'm gonna call this
person a person this person was like a
little disappointed in me though because
they were and i was like thinking he
kind of should have told me what was
really up
yeah and like you should be a warning
about that you know like you might not
be into it but we did a video about that
and i was i was sleeping i started
falling asleep and then his or her voice
was so soothing I started believing it
was a woman he kidding you did it so I
went through it and it was right after
you know it's the only reason I'm
sharing this story is because it was
during that when I realized two things
one none of guys to UM to I realized I
really don't like just [ __ ] with
people or like just doing sexual things
with no actual emotional intimacy I
realized that's what I really wanted so
that and I know it was because of that
experience where I was like I really
want an emotional connection with
someone and then I started realizing all
these girls that come on the channel I'm
like whatever they're just the you know
like I could be friends with them like
why do I have to try to [ __ ] everything
I see no so I decided to be I was like
you know what I'm cool with going I have
attractive friends but I'm just friends
in but Veronica I've known her for ten
plus years and I just couldn't get past
the fact of how attracted I was to her
for all these years and how deep of a
connection we had and then it led to
what it is now and she knows about that
incident but um yeah I I told her about
that and she was like I'm worried for
you because of that yeah she made sure I
that STD tested before like we ever did
anything so yeah yeah yeah yeah we
carefully so let me ask you this did you
two get together kind of like you had
one hot cook up after being years of
friends or what's it kind of like hey
let me take you out oh no
yeah we like fooled around one time when
we were like in our mid teens and it was
just this one time many many years later
we like fooled around again but she was
but any time we started like messing
around because of the state she was in
in the state I was in she wouldn't wanna
she would push me away or cut it off and
then one day one day oh man I totally
share a story with you would be so
[ __ ] up sure they'll have to feel one
day when we're alone good yeah what but
one day we just start like we do start
like messing around and stuff and cheese
I'm constantly like I would be honest
with her I'd be like I had masturbated
to you for years right haha and you are
no that's one thing I really like that
to your very very OB yeah really yeah
and I thought I was open I've had women
tell me your little too open with me who
you know but wait trust me I've got in
the to open thing many times but um I
just don't want to have her liar I don't
want to feel the need to hide something
I don't know why but um anyway so
Veronica one day calls me up and she's
and she's telling me like she's having
these thoughts about the kind of guy she
wants she's been single for almost a
year at this point and she's really been
working on herself and that's what i was
doing so what happened was was i was an
individual who was like I me get my [ __ ]
together and then I started doing a lot
of personal developing again going to
therapy and then she was doing similar
things and then we I grew as a person
she grew as a person and those two
people just clicked and then we started
hooking up and it was [ __ ] awesome so
[ __ ] hot oven and I was like it
started off like you know we're just
friends were just it's just cool and
then one day it really dawned on me I
don't want her to hook up with anyone
else but me like I I will not be I will
not be cool with it and then I asked her
to be my girlfriend cuz I was
like I really it was the first time
where something so natural happened
where I was like I really want this girl
to be my girlfriend Oh [ __ ] love her
I wish she was here right now you were
bed buddy like me and my ex work man yep
Benny dude there's that point were you
like you not wait a minute no I don't
want anybody else touching her yeah so
yeah yeah it goes beyond jealousy it's
just like you're like I want to keep
this something I mean she's an actress
and she still since we've been together
she hasn't had to do a kissing scene or
anything with anyone else since but I
know as an actress it's gonna come down
the road and that's that's what worries
not worries me but my concern with the
direction we're going would have to be
you know I'm doing my thing and I'm
going to I'm going to be transitioning
more into writing and stuff and I just
got an acting gig for like I got offered
an acting gig on a web series and
Veronica she's going to be going big and
going places and it's like how do you
manage these two careers and make it
work you know like that's where I'm
that's the only like people are like why
would you marry her you know forever and
then I'm like well this is the reason
why we're not sure where were or will be
when our careers are really up there you
know like how can we if we can maintain
that and make it work than totally I'm
gonna absolutely because you still want
good journey yeah exactly exactly you
know but I tell you this as an actor
myself if I expand not become pig I will
never do it sexy ah but no Emma that's
my buddy right there and as a producer
and writer um I will insist that you do
a sex scene with Veronica be like please
Tyrone do this for me fulfill a fantasy
I have I like the watch likewise my
thing I never actually done anything
with
well I've been how open-minded Noel is
maybe i'll send you that p yeah yeah a
man can't talk too much about Noel but
you should probably come visit LA and
I'm given them like our subscribers so
much fuel right now yeah cuz 50 you can
for you can say something could make a
joke you can [ __ ] up and say something
and they take it and run with it yeah I
a so where I've been [ __ ] mom but
John bow for about three months or so of
course I've never touched the girl but
no people are like someone tweeted
Veronica once saying hey I'm sorry I
Ryan cheated on you and I was like why
oh it's because like if they would see
other female friends am i coming on the
channel Veronica hadn't been on for like
a month so they thought oh maybe were
like I did something [ __ ] up you know
and short you mean what's up he started
an argument no it didn't start an
argument now I mean I was like I she
knows that some people are just dumb Oh
me it happened with me before when I was
with Sarah um someone had sent me a
message and I said again you girls a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and yeah absolutely TOA
james said what's up now James had the
name of James just happened to be of one
of her exes so yeah yeah so that caused
a big thing and she basically had to
prove to me that she wasn't with him or
touching him or anything my man Bishop
phone records emails like as I was I was
pissed yeah yeah because I was like wait
a minute wait a min you know so the more
I put it together she was dellinger but
uh it was just yeah yeah no that's if
it's some [ __ ] that people say it like
it does it starts to really upset me
like there's this one guy like you know
people
it on me and and I did a podcast
recently where I did talk about how
every once in a while that does start to
bring me down like I asked for it pretty
much it like it's my fault i Ken hey all
right so but every once in a while it
does start to bring me down a little bit
but when it really bothers me is if they
say something about someone else